in a completely unscientific poll
representative only of the portion of
our audience who chose to participate we
asked who do you think is next to be
indicted in the Trump Russia
investigation and the results are very
overwhelming 42% of the 13,000 people
that voted believe Donald Trump jr. will
be the next Trump associate indicted 24%
believe Roger stone 21% Jared Kushner 8%
Carter page and 5% believed that it is
somebody else now three months ago I
would have said Jared Kushner and I
would not have agreed with these results
but I'm increasingly thinking that there
is something to it being Don jr. he
seemed to be in a lot of trouble the
Trump Tower meeting stuff indeed yeah I
know where you are gonna hit pretty home
well it's interesting how like two of
those names are people we've interviewed
right Roger stone yes our page that's
true I had to pick just one I think it
would go to Carter Carter page you think
it's Carter Wow
so you are very very much at odds with
the audience a few comments notable
about the poll that people also sent in
I wanted to be Donald Trump jr. but I
think they're saving him as a bargaining
chip there is something to that which is
you slowly build up to those who will
most unnerve Trump if it were to be them
another comment oh god I hope it's Don
junior to see that stupid look drain off
his face would be like an early
Christmas and another comment I selected
other because there was no
all-of-the-above box but the question
was now who do you think will be
indicted it's who do you think will next
be indicted in time so 13,000 votes on
this poll quite a quite a significant
sample but of course it is people who
are subscribers to the David Pakman show
I'm going to send these results right
now to the special counsel yeah bowler
we'll take a look at this